we have the story from fox 5 atlanta
marjorie taylor greene was victim of
swatting at rome residence police
confirmed
so uh this is this is a terrifying story
it is that a bunch of outlets have
reported this is a prank a swatting for
those that aren't familiar i think most
of you are but just in case is when
someone calls the police and says
there's a violent crime currently taking
place so that a swat team shows up to
your house
potentially kills you people have died
from this and it's horrifying i can't
imagine there's a story about this guy
cops surround his house he has no idea
what's going on he comes out armed the
cops shoot and kill him imagine first of
all that guy being the victim having no
idea why the cops are at your house then
think about you know i'm not saying it's
worse but that cop
who was told there's a guy who had to
murder his wife or something we need you
to save her life and he shows up and
he's like i got to stop this guy and
then it turns out someone tricked you
into killing an innocent man
talk about the nightmare scenario that
swatting is and they went after marjorie
taylor green's house this is uh it was
look i'm gonna it was a trans activist
this is the reporting was they told the
police that the reason they did it was
because they oppose her position on on
trans uh kids because marjorie taylor
green recently introduced a bill that
would make it a felony to give
transgender surgery or medication to
children
so i'm curious too uh james because you
talk about revolution and where we're at
where does this fit in with you know
their power grabs the power structures
like what is what is this
okay so just to mention by the way the
last time i actually talked to marjorie
like a month ago and that's exactly this
is exactly the subject not swatting but
but trans activism and the surgeries and
everything to the children is exactly
what we talked about so it's kind of
funny i like marjorie um so what's going
on here
is uh kind of an unbridled demonstration
of being willing to step outside of the
boundaries the normal boundaries of
society in order to get your way
so marjorie taylor green
proposes a bill this is the way that we
do things if the bill passes the bill
passes there are lots of bills that pass
that people like or don't like on either
side and that's just the name of the
game maybe it doesn't pass maybe
whatever but the idea that you're now
going in to to do this act of
intimidation
that basically sends this huge signal
out right terror outright terror literal
definition there's there's few things
there are there are some things but
there are a few things scarier than the
idea like you said of armed angry
police officers thinking something is
going on that requires desperate
measures surrounding your house or
whatever at 1am in the you know right in
the middle of the night you're asleep
you don't know what's going on and all
of a sudden this is happening and so
what this is it's just another another
escalation in the kind of pattern of
intimidation that we're seeing um you
know
what were they doing outside the supreme
court justices houses they were
protesting but then judge kavanaugh has
a credible threat to his life involved
with this and what do you have well it
turns out
funny enough you mentioned trans
activists the exact same trans activist
who got me kicked off of twitter the
exact same one
alejandra carabello
advocated for more of this the the
intimidation tactics intimidating of the
supreme court justices even in this
environment the exact same one so what
you have is people who are stepping
outside of the frame of society they're
breaking the taunt of society to get
their way and they feel perfectly
entitled to be able to do it because
they've got some trumped up idea about
uh
what do you call it systemic or
structural well demanding that you stay
within the lines oh yeah absolutely
that's the repressive tolerance again or
liberating tolerance actually we saw
this with the gravel institute
after january 6 the gravel institute
tweeted that they supported the action
but not the people the people were the
wrong ones to do it and they deleted the
tweet people were like you're saying
that you thought that was good and they
were like yup and then they were like
y'all are crazy and then they deleted it
like okay maybe we shouldn't admit that
that's the crazy thing
you have people who are lucid they're
they're they understand what they're
doing they know how the machine works
they know why they're claiming you can't
do it and while they do it but then you
have the dumb people who mindlessly
march along completely clueless and
don't care sam harris comes off to me
like
he is
you know what's what's what's the
opposite of sentient
[Laughter]
sam harris comes off to me as the
fulfillment of the the critical theory
magnum opus called dialectic of
enlightenment to be honest with you
explain so dialectic of enlightenment
was this book written in 44 and
rewritten and published again in 47 by
uh max horkheimer and theodore darno the
two kind of principal critical theorists
of the era
and um what they said is that you know
you start off with the enlightenment you
enter into this phase denouncing myth
and entering into rationality but what
happens is through the dialectical
process of transformation of
enlightenment rationality itself becomes
its own mythology and you literally
enter into this new kind of religious
order of rationality that completely
divorces you from being genuinely
rational you're now operating within
this myth and i read this book and i was
like this is insane this is just crazy
and then i looked at sam harris and i
was like oh
okay so so uh maybe what's the opposite
of lucid
uh
murky murky clouded well so the way i
see it is sam harris is dude it's almost
like looking through cataracts instead
of lucid vision it's like he's got this
fog in front of his eyes but i don't
think that's the right way to describe
it because hypnosis is a better way to
just yeah that's a good way to put it
because even if your eyes are cloudy you
can be thinking clearly yeah even if
your information is bad you wouldn't say
something as insane about dead kids
he's he's in a state of like
cult hypnosis
that has stripped away his individuality
his agency and now he's just mindlessly
droning along
there there are people like that
but then there are people who are fully
aware they're breaking the rules and
they know it and they don't care like i
mentioned the gravel institute oh yeah
totally totally um so this is something
a lot of people don't really fully
appreciate about our current moment is
that we're actually not dealing with
just politics at all we're dealing with
it's not even like the soul or the
future of america we're dealing with two
fundamentally different conceptions of
what it means to be a human being
or literally mean down to religious
roots of what it means to be a person
and uh
kind of the american answer kind of
comes from john locke who in essence is
like well none of us are god so none of
us deserve political authority so we're
going to secure life liberty and
property so people can think for
themselves and disagree amongst one
another because we don't have all the
answers and so the american system
really the question is who deserves
political authority and thomas jefferson
and benjamin franklin these guys meet
together in their answer james madison
we're like
nobody deserves it but we'll lend it to
you under these conditions and that's
called a republic yeah but the answer
these leftists believe fundamentally
believe marxist-style leftists
fundamentally believe that they're the
only enlightened conscious people on the
planet that understand how supposed to
work so they not only should have
political authority they're entitled to
political authority so they get to step
outside of the rules because they're
fully entitled to have political
authority over everything you want to
read that one yeah okay so it's
pronounced gravel gravel okay the gravel
institute um when was that uh one eight
twenty one so january eighth uh two days
after january six okay got you uh but if
leftist had stormed the capital you'd
support it in scare quotes yes they are
fighting for a good cause fascists are
fighting for a very bad cause this
should not be difficult this is the this
is the thesis statement of repressive
tolerance written right again that's
exactly the thesis statement if we went
down to the thesis statement of
repressive tolerance in the essay he
says that liberating tolerance can be
summarized in basically a single
sentence and he says that
tolerance must be extended to movements
from the left it must be withdrawn from
movements from the right
which is exactly why
they never seem to complain about the
soviet union or the culture revolution
and these other countries that currently
exist that are still communist but
they're
they're always screaming nazi germany
that's right that's exactly right the
fascists the fascists that's right they
they never
recognize that if you actually read
marx's different stages of history where
you bail out of capitalism you have your
revolution and you have a dictatorship
of the proletariat that's the next stage
that's called socialism that socialism
is actually a fascist state that is
supposed to dialectically unwind to a
utopia which it's not going to do
there's a meme
and this female journalist personality
leftist tweeted
people often point out how socialism has
failed in so many countries but if it
doesn't work you don't just give up you
keep trying and then someone respond
like they said like like cooking if you
make a mistake you just start you know
try again and someone responded with
like oops burn the souffle and it's a
picture of
skulls yeah yeah brutal murder well i
mean that is actually their idea so the
idea is i mean to get deeper into the
philosophy behind it that you have this
thing out floating in the world this is
hegel okay so hegel precedes marx mark's
retools hegel and makes it material
hegel's idea is that there's this
literal concept of god called the
absolute idea so it's the perfected idea
the absolute you know platonic form of
how everything in the universe should
operate it's it's the deity
but we don't have access to that so it
splits into two sides the theoretical
idea and the practical idea the
theoretical idea is our idea about it
our guess about it our theory or how we
think the world's supposed to work
practical ideas how it actually gets
implemented usually through the state
by the way he said that the state is a
divine idea as it exists on earth and
this is just to help you understand if
you ever see the left start gloating
about praxis
yes that's right and so what the idea of
praxis is supposed to bring theory and
practice together again so the
theoretical idea and practicality are
supposed to come together which
reinstitutes the absolute
so the idea is that when you put the
soviet union into practice
and 30 something 40 something million
people die what you were doing is you
you're exposing the contradiction
between the theoretical and the
practical so what you're actually doing
is learning more about why it didn't
work this time
and so you thank those people or in
hegel's world words i mean literally
this is a quote from hegel history uses
people and then discards them so they
were discarded on the altar of the god
of history sacrificed to the god of
history so that history can move to its
perfected end point you should watch
full metal alchemist
you know i no i know what it is i've
seen like some parts of it uh but i
haven't actually watched all the way
through but i'm i'm sure that this is
going to relate because what hegel was
was a hermeticist which is an alchemist
there's two two uh anime is an animes
that i recommend or manga um attack on
titan and full metal alchemist because
they directly deal so uh fullmetal
alchemist brotherhood which is the
actual it follows the manga and i know a
lot of people out there they might not
be fans of any of this stuff graphic
novels or whatever but seriously
consider this because what it deals with
is
powerful elites who want to sacrifice
the people for more power that's full
metal alchemist and i want to spoil it
if you're going to check it out but it
very much deals with this how the
population of throughout history are
sacrificed for more and more power and
then attack on titan um it's funny
someone posted a meme of jordan peterson
saying you should watch attack on titan
and it's not real but uh if you're a fan
of jordan peterson and you watch that
show you're gonna be like i wouldn't be
surprised if you actually did say it
because it deals with privilege and
historical racism and all of that stuff
in those shows so they're very very
interesting but anyway believe it or not
i actually know a manga and that's death
note i actually know oh amazing amazing
that one's cool that's really cool um
you know i got questions about this
marcus is the guy who wrote
marcus and this is the 60s it's what was
the name of the paper again repressive
tolerance so they're saying that
leftists should be there it should be
tolerated violence from leftists should
be tolerated but from the right not even
the thought should enter their mind why
that sounds out of balance without a
balanced right and left to function
together you would i would think that
the system would fail okay yeah because
it's they believe that what happens is
that the system is inherently corrupt
and the system is inherently designed to
reproduce itself and only the true
leftist understands how to break free of
the what they call literally they call
this the problem of reproduction
so society reproduces itself by all of
its means and mechanisms so only that
which steps out of the mechanisms of
reproduction is to be condoned
so anything else on the right what
you're doing is
you have a oppressive society a
repressive society a harmful society a
racist society a sexist society a class
of society and if you don't reject that
utterly in fact he called it the great
refusal marcus did if you don't reject
that utterly and step completely outside
of it all you're doing is becoming
complicit doesn't this sound familiar to
the world we live in today you're
becoming complicit in those harms and
keeping those harms going so in some
sense you bore you bear moral
responsibility for every act of racism
that comes up later in life
in the world
for every act of uh you know
capitalist exploitation or whatever that
happens later in the world if you don't
completely refuse the system then you're
complicit in that so they don't want
balance they think that balance is a
form of compromise that keeps oppression
alive
so you have to have a complete he calls
it again the great refusal of the entire
terms of the existing society and the
question is how do you solve the problem
of reproduction
and the answer that they gave was
relentless criticism problematization of
everything
quite literally marcus says that it must
be relentless negative thinking and
negative thinking will become positive
by
actually freeing up the ideal society
that is contained within
the existing corrupt form and we go back
to the alchemy this is alchemy a lot of
people don't know what the religion of
alchemy is about but the the it is a
religion by the way it's a very old many
thousands of years old religious view
and it's that when in the act of
creation god co-creates himself and the
universe okay the exact same instant of
creation
but he makes himself in the universe so
every single thing whether it's his pen
or you know whatever me you the crystal
balls whatever it is on the table
there's some aspect of the divine
contained within that but it's in its
mundane form and so what you have to do
is use the magical spells of alchemy to
break open the mundane form of the thing
so that the divine form can come out
lead is a mundane medal so you have to
do the magic spells break open the
nature of lead at a metaphysical level
and then the seed of gold inside will
transform the entire lump of metal into
gold which is the divine metal death is
the mundane form of existence so you
have to break open and make the elixir
of life that will break open the
death and turn it into life which is
divine and the same thing is being
expressed by marcus in these essays that
he's writing um
especially repressive tolerance here is
that if you break open the form of
society then what can happen is that the
ideal divine version of it heaven or as
henry drew i mentioned earlier put it
the kingdom of god
as it exists on earth can emerge from
the oppressive forms that are trapping
it and holding it back do they
acknowledge that when you break open a
society it can also
you know emulate or
i mean they should listen to gandalf
talking to sauron because he's like
whoever breaks a thing to see how it
works has left the path of wisdom
that's
no they if they're that's the problem is
they think that the world is
intrinsically bad
right
so this isn't this turns out not to
necessarily be the hermetic side if we
go back to hegel what did he do he
combined hermeticism with another old
religion called gnosticism an old
mystery religion the gnostics believe
that being itself we've been cast into a
prison
by
the character in genesis that gets
called god but he's actually the
demiurge he's actually a demon and so
he's he's not the real supreme being
behind this the scenes and so the whole
whole of being is a prison where you
don't get to be who you want you have to
grow up you have a body you didn't ask
for so maybe you have to transition
maybe it shackles you to having babies
and so you know you have to be able to
have infinite abortion you have to be
able to transform your body this
view that your your very existence and
existence itself is a prison in the form
of society as a prison is the mindset
that they're in so there's no balance
and if all you do is burn down the
prison that's still better
than leaving people in it this is
fascinating i want to say though they're
wrong of course they're wrong life is a
a gift yeah body is a is we've been like
i look at it this way i saw a meme
earlier
and it was it was god and the devil and
they were arm wrestling and it was some
political cartoon that said only a fool
would create his own enemy and then i
responded with like when we program
video games we make the villains on
purpose like your argument is you know
childish
um
but this idea of you know your body
being a prison or whatever when we play
video games
you play a character which has limits
it's enjoyable it is done on purpose for
something we want to do you know you get
a character the character's weak you
make it strong where you start like how
many how many women played mario it's
like oh now you're a guy it's like they
don't complain that mario can't turn
into a woman or be a different character
it's like you play the game you enjoy it
life is a gift you got it's not
particularly long but it's long enough
in a lot of ways and you get to
experience this this slice of existence
and that's uh that's that's unique and
it's magical so speaking of video games
sorry you know i'll give you a second
but uh
you ever play like so believe it or not
i know last time i was here i was like
don't play video games
but
believe it or not i used to play video
games and i played i got really into at
one point this final fantasy series and
i was playing final fantasy 10 which is
that legendary kind of you know epic
story everybody gets all excited about
it and it turns out that the game is set
up so that you can actually
you know get these crystals or whatever
they are and just keep making your
characters stronger and stronger and
stronger and it turns out i was playing
on my brother's account or whatever and
he left he went to san diego for three
weeks and i'm just playing and i'm bored
like just chilling every night playing
the game and i made these characters
like super strong so even like the
little [ __ ] you know weak um magic
users or whatever they aren't supposed
to be able to hit with their stick very
hard it would hit and it'd be like all
nines and kill everything in one hit and
it's like he came back and he was like
what the heck the game's not even fun
so when you go god mode in a game it's
not even fun anymore exactly it takes
everything away from it and so yeah this
idea that the body is a prison you
completely misses the uh the give and
take of reality and of life that makes
life interesting and worth living it's
really a sad and miserable existence and
i do have tremendous pity for people
that are sucked into this kind of way of
thinking
but ultimately i think this is where
that the drive comes from thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there
you